as with other questions I am most
interested in the strategy and the
approach that you take this question
rather than actually the machinery are
just crunching through the numbers we're
in an expansion exam that's what really
matters so once you to look carefully at
this question and I want you to think
about okay I know I know there's a lot
of stuff there and there's a lot of
stuff there but I want you to figure out
what might be the most efficient path
through this because there are some very
inefficient paths through this though
they just don't take you off on the
garden park so I want you to have a look
you've got one two three four terms
count them what do you see in common
with every single one of the terms they
have the same base they're all log base
B so that's really nice there's another
thing that I can see in common with a
lot of them but not every single one
what do you see if you have a look at
the one two three first three terms they
all have a two at the front as a
coefficient right so I've got two
targets that I'm immediately looking at
as okay if I can take advantage of those
that'll be good now we said the first
three terms all have that - this term
also has it - it's just hiding right
where is it it's up in power right so
the very first thing I should do bless
you is get that two out the front
because then I can get rid of it across
the board okay so let me write that down
I'm going to have to log base B this all
of this stuff is going to remain
unchanged but at this point once I've
reached the last term I can manipulate
that and bring that throughout the front
like so see a common factor of two all
the way I'm just going to divide
everything by 2 which gives me this
like so and I now look and I see that
first thing you mentioned which is in
common across the board is a log base
speed but I've got one log on the left
and I've got a whole bunch of mobs on
the right if only there was some way to
combine all those ones on the right so
you've got one on both sides a weight I
can with these three logs that are being
added and subtracted what does that mean
for log Wars these guys will end up
being multiplied into the same log and
this one will end up being divided so
let's write that out you're going to get
log base B of okay how's it look so far
we're good okay alright now when you
have a look at this you're like I can at
least get rid of the log base B etc but
this is still a bit of a mess right so
when you have a look I can say well X is
going to be equal to that have a look at
the top here right this is something
else that you recognize from algebra
what is that difference of squares and
then on the denominator here you've got
these two guys you want fractions on
fractions
that's not very nice what am I going to
do with this you can put these on a
common denominator together right but if
you do that you're still going to have a
faction faction is nothing wrong with it
I just think it's for me mentally I want
to get rid of fractions of the factors
as quickly as I can
it's just easier to work with so for me
the easy thing to do is to multiply this
whole fraction by a on a now you can
just as easily add this will be fine but
again I'm trying to think of an
efficient part the part that just is
less work on my brain and this is going
to get rid of that quickly so I've got
this on the top
what are you get on the bottom oh that's
handy right so you can see cancel cancel
and there's your solution okay so it's
nice when you get shown all this is that
oh this is this is the nicer but I want
point out to you if you think before you
start simplifying it's a bit like trig
identities
do you remember only how to do them in
the ap1 you can go round and round in
circles you see all the different trig
identities that you are aware of and
it's going to get worse because you're
going to learn more trig identities but
it's smarter to look first just like
you're planning an essay out and think
about what structures you can take
advantage of and go in that direction
don't just drive aimlessly head towards
your destination restrictions are they
just there for fun ok why are there
restrictions there for two reasons
number one they're actually being nice
to you so I've pointed out before in
fact that question I did in green right
over here before when I started there
were instructions there but they were
implied so it's actually more work to
think about what the restrictions are
without being told them can you see that
this this year is implied by this do you
see that but there's actually another
functional reason why they do that
because this is not the only thing you
can do to go through it for example if I
wanted to I could have written the
left-hand side like this right
now we've talked about how this and this
are kind of equal they're kind of equal
they are only equal if you say this
right because otherwise you can put
negatives here and you can't put
negatives here and they're not equal
okay but if you do have this restriction
which they are very helpfully supplied
for you then you actually can go down
this line of working and you'll still
get answers at the end in fact I believe
the solutions and some people have
whipped them already I think they do go
down this path and then their second
last line is this now if you think about
this carefully you recognize that this
has more solutions than this doesn't it
if this is your last line what would you
write you write plus or minus write like
if that was 25 on the right hand side
you'd say plus or minus 5 but in fact
the domain restriction that they
provided for you helps you recognize
even if you wrote that and then that
you've got a mechanism for getting to
here because only one of those solutions
is valid
because only one of them is in the
domain that's being supplied so if
you're wondering why that's all there
partly because it's implied by the logs
but also help you out if you went
through a different part